um you said you liked you liked this
what is it that you liked about that
that um
he's portraying gay men in a feminine
way I feel like in media we don't really
get that he's one of the few that rap
before like the gay people basically and
I just find that Lit but I should get
confused over there bro you better say
something yeah you just said he's
portraying gay men in a feminine way
yeah I mean yeah yeah sorry that's what
it is like no but no this gay men that
are masculine I know but every time you
see gay men in the media they tend to be
feminine
um not really not well me no I see gay
men who I'm asking on the media okay
name one
um
you could name all you could name RuPaul
oh you can name him you could name
um uh what's the British uh comedian's
name
um
with the Eddie Izzard
I'm not saying they're gay but I'm just
saying a lot of people when it comes to
feminine men is what is portrayed but um
you interestingly said that you liked
that or you said you like him if your
son came
if you had a child and your son said
Mommy look I want to do this what would
be your response I would like do
whatever you want
period
I just feel like in in the world today
if you want to do what you want to do if
you want to be gay be gay if you want to
be straight you can be straight right
but that what was that okay
that was gay yeah he's gay
but it's interesting no he's gay you
know what's interesting how you're like
celebrating it I'm not celebrating I
know I mean you thought it was like cool
you just said you thought it was cool
that like that you're seeing that in the
media but if it's like a super feminine
woman
like who's just in her feminine or super
masculine man like I don't I would guess
you probably wouldn't have the same
reaction no I would there's a lot of
girls I listen to that they do the exact
same thing like they're twerking they're
being lit no no I said I said feminine
not twerking no but that's
um You Go I mean though like there's
feminine girls who do the same though I
don't I don't I don't think so when
they're not feminine
I I would say Feminine is typically has
like Purity
yeah so when I said earlier that you
know women create types of men that they
don't want right it's very interesting
because when I said women create the
types of men they don't want and then
that came on you're like oh yeah I love
him and I'm like yeah that's because
you're creating the types of because you
wouldn't want that type of guy as your
man would you
right but you're celebrating that a lot
of women celebrate that kind of stuff
and a lot of women push that kind of
stuff but like I said they're creating
the types of men that they don't want to
who's managed that because that's
somebody's son
someone's you know brother whatever and
I'm just saying the attacker when it
comes to the attack on masculinity I
think you know he's clearly got a beard
you know if you're trans you're trans if
you're gay you're gay if you're lesbian
lesbian but what that was to me was an
attack on the masculine image because it
it took the masculine images like a
beard bald head and it feminized it it
put a dress on it yeah that for me like
I really dislike I got like this taste
of things like that I don't like it's so
confusing to me like if you're gonna be
trans why don't you just actually
complete so you having a beard but
presenting is to me that's so confusing
it makes me uncomfortable actually just
I don't know why it's just so weird to
me I don't get I generally don't
understand it like
I can understand that because
[Music]
um
when when I see
men and they are gay but they're
feminine like they got the wig on the
whole outfit I'm like well and I've
heard people ask like well do you want
to be a woman no I don't want to be a
woman I'm just a gay man who likes to be
feminine and it's
it's confusing it's like but you you
portray this but you don't want to be
that and it's like well why don't you
just be a masculine gay dude just
because you're gay doesn't mean you have
to be feminine or
that so I can I can understand that
do you feel like the reason for so many
like effeminate men is because fathers
are not around yeah I think that a lot
of times if someone wasn't raised with a
dad I can like tell and hear it in their
they don't even have to like tell me and
like I can just kind of hear it in the
way they talk and like their voice
um and I think like typically if they're
if they're older it might be a little
bit harder but like guys in their 20s
it's like really easy to tell they
didn't grow up with a dad or a masculine
like figure around
because I I never and I had to find what
it was to be a man I literally had to go
and seek men who I thought were
masculine in some ways I think even I
would say in my 20s like my early 20s I
was like okay cool I kind of realized
that the way I am right now isn't really
working so I need to find but because I
never had that farther figure I had to
go on a search for myself I think back
in the day a lot of people had that
where they had to where they said I have
to find
a masculine figure and a lot of them got
it from the culture the music culture
entertainment and there was more
masculine men that were in that
um sphere in that area to where they
were able to look up to them
um whether it was rap music whether they
were on TV and it was just like the
image was more masculine nowadays
is not as much as that in your face like
this is a masculine it's like oh here's
a a trans man here's a gay man is not so
much pushing the masculine agenda but
more so the feminine isn't it more the
problem I mean I don't really I don't
care if someone's gay I don't care if
someone's trans I don't really give a
monkeys like all of this stuff it's like
people you know I'm kind of Live and Let
Live Like libertarian I think people
could do what they want to do but
I think what is a bit of a problem is
that the excuse is I'm just imagining
how to say it say it no no it's just
that the uh the the poor heterosexual
man you know suffering now because
because you know now it's like for
example like Bukowski I don't know if
you guys know the writer Bukowski he's a
great he was a great writer this was a
dude who at the age who worked for the
Post Office all his life at the age of
50 gave up to become a writer and he was
like an alcoholic he lived in Los
Angeles he would like sleep on a
mattress but he became really popular
he'd do these big readings and he'd get
all these young girls you know young
women coming to see him and he ended up
sleeping with these young women and he
wrote whole books about you know these
25 year olds that he was you know
sleeping with and everything now if you
try to get that published Now by
mainstream publisher I guarantee you'd
get just thrown out of the you know you
get thrown out but those were great
books and his experience was valid right
so why can we not
talk about that but we can talk about
all these other things and I'm not
necessarily denigrating the other things
either it's just that why is one thing
being pushed down to the expense of
everything else you know no I agree and
it's almost like even even your initial
reaction and it's not just you it's like
like I've caught you know I'm sure at
some point in time before I was red
pilled I had the same thing but it's
like it's like there's just certain
things in society that are like
celebrated like naturally like why are
we pushing like girls twerking why are
we pushing men in like in like Harry
Styles when he was in a dress like why
are we celebrating that more than like a
traditional family I agree you know what
I think I've come to the conclusion I
think Western culture I'd like to
celebrate negativity and I just I don't
know what it is everything about
negative or what we what goes against
the grain of the standard we just
celebrate it so like he said if it's
um seeing a video like that if it's seen
um even if you're like
like men doing crying oh we celebrate so
much negativity and my friend once told
me he's like he's like Western culture
makes more money of trauma than it does
anything else so it will always push
things that are traumatic because it
will make money everything else is like
what's the point so I feel like that's
why we see it it may not be uh more so
celebrated but it's more so gets people
talking gives people talking and it
doesn't matter what it is but if it's
like you said goes against the grain you
always you're always going to have the
group that agrees but if it's big enough
you're gonna have an even bigger group
that disagrees and either one is
generating money
yeah I think I think you that your point
earlier though I think I think there is
money to be made now in in hating on
hating on men basically and I think
that's why one of the reasons why so
many people jump on that that bandwagon
you know yeah yeah I mean even with like
brand deals and stuff you get
um so much more if your audience is
women so that's right that's why he was
all these guys that are these samps
pandering like the Derek Janks or
whatever as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible